monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
mes chers collègues j'ai l'honneur
remplacé aujourd'hui le président
Stéphane Artano qui vous prie de
l'excuser car il est actuellement à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et participe à
nos travaux en visio-conférence dans le
cadre de son étude sur le Foncia
agricole dans les outre-mer la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer
organise ce matin une table ronde dédiée
à Mayotte en effet après une première
audition avec la Fédération nationale
des sociétés d'aménagement fonciers et
d'établissement rural la fn s'affaire le
2 mars dernier nous rapporteur vivait
aborder la situation à Mayotte qui a
précisément la particularité de ne pas
avoir de sa faire
le président le FN s'affer Monsieur
Emmanuel yest nous a aussi annoncé
qu'ils se rendrait prochainement sur
l'île afin d'écouter les acteurs locaux
à ce sujet
pour Driss pour dresser le panorama de
la situation à Mayotte nous allons
entendre un tour de rôle ce matin donc
le président du conseil départemental
monsieur bannissa ou Séni la direction
de l'alimentation de l'agriculture et de
la forêt de Mayotte représentée par
Monsieur Philippe Gou son directeur qui
est accompagné de Bastien chalagirot
directeur à adjoint l'établissement
public foncier et d'aménagement de
Mayotte représentée par Monsieur Yves
Michel Denard directeur général qui a
accompagné le Monsieur David van coteren
directeur du pôle stratégie agricole la
chambre de l'agriculture de la pêche et
de l'aquaculture de Mayotte représentée
par son directeur Monsieur Stéphane
Allard la Fédération mahoraise des
associations environnementales
représentées par Monsieur neylan atouman
à Tibou secrétaire général le syndicat
des Jeunes Agriculteurs de Mayotte
monsieur
voilà moeva président qui a accompagné
de Martin
coordinateur et enfin la mutualité
sociale agricole d'Armorique avec Madame
Karine nouvelle directrice générale
monsieur Yoann Auffret directement
adjoint cet organisme gère la protection
sociale les exploitants agricoles et de
leur famille depuis 2015 dans un premier
temps je vous demanderai dans votre
propos liminaire d'une dizaine de
minutes de pointer les éléments
principaux caractéristiques selon vous
le foncier agricole Mahorais puis les
rapporteurs interviendront pour des
précisions complémentaires sur la base
du questionnaire qu'il vous ont
adressait et enfin je donnerai la parole
à nos autres collègues ici présents que
je remercie chère Marie Mercier donc le
président
n'étant pas connecté pour l'instant je
laisserai
la parole à Monsieur Philippe Gou
direction de l'alimentation de la
l'agriculture et de la forêt de Mayotte
bonjour
est-ce que vous nous entendez bien parce
que nous avons un peu de mal à vous
entendre
est-ce que
oui bonjour Nous vous entendons
parfaitement
je vous laisse la parole
nous avons eu quelques difficultés à
propos
cela fonctionne
nous avons vous remercier de vous avoir
associé à cette table ronde puisque un
sujet d'importance à Mayotte qui est le
foncier que la question du foncier
agricole
on intervention luminaire sera assez
rapide pour dire que tout d'abord le
principalement et de façon partagée sur
le territoire
ce qui peut sembler normal qu'on
n'a pas réussi à avoir
et cela est également vrai au niveau de
l'ensemble des services de l'État local
qui se sont approprié cette question
dans un cadre
qui est le nom
du disque dur à savoir le développement
d'une agriculture professionnelle au
service d'une ambition de souveraineté
alimentaire du territoire
parce que c'est dans cette optique qu'au
niveau du ministère de la Culture nous
avons vu la question du
boursier dont on a coutume de dire à
Mayotte qui verra
d'euphémisme et on en dénonce souvent
l'absence et tous les collègues qui sont
autour de cette table ronde virtuelle
pour en témoigner toutefois si la
question de la partie du foncier est une
question récurrente à Mayotte
c'est pour vous donc à travers le prisme
qui est disponible pour le déploiement
et la mise en œuvre de nos politiques
publiques que nous souhaitons apporter
le sujet je pense que certains d'entre
nous
en tout cas
non c'est
nous allons y revenir plus en détail
notamment par rapport aux superficie
recensée en matière sur le territoire
[Musique]
qui existe le foncier agricole existe on
y reviendra en parlant de superficie
donc j'ai voté par contre ce qui est
notre colocation
c'est de disposer de pouvoir disponible
et là c'est tout un autre
vous pouvez imaginer et que c'est la
peur
la capacité des uns et les autres
approuve s'investir dans une activité
professionnelle
si vous ne le permettez je reviendrai
très rapidement sur la démarche que nous
avons conduite de quelques années
en activant un environnement dont vous
allez le voir qui évolue très rapidement
ce qui est particulièrement éclairant à
ce titre à la demande du préfet de
Mayotte en 2019 nous avons lancé les
états généraux de l'agriculture à
Mayotte en associant bien entendu du
parlementaire le président
la chambre et évidemment l'ensemble des
acteurs autour de trois thématiques qui
avaient
identité comme prioritaire
les marchés d'informer
le foncier agricole en se donnant pour
ambitions
de terrasse du centre pragmatique et
sur le volet du français
avait été offensé les enjeux de
sanctualisation de ce faciliter le
terrain agricole au profit de la mise en
oeuvre professionnelle la régulation
d'occupation foncière des agriculteurs
professionnels et puis bien entendu
l'installation
parmi les actions qui avaient été
validées à cette époque ils font
beaucoup de suivi
d'actualités
l'Union aussi la possibilité d'avoir en
place la prescription
actuelle dès 21 2022 la conduite
régularisation du foncier départemental
sur des points particulièrement bien
identifiés parallèlement la conduite
d'une opération d'installation au titre
sur un titre appartenant à l'État
privé de l'État c'est un point très
important sur lequel nous avons nous
allons revenir les opérations de zone
agricoles expérimentale conduite par
l'établissement public fonciers
pour sécuriser les exploitations
agricoles y compris en permettant aux AG
riculteurs
2020 des sujets très importants
des ambitions
et qui a beaucoup pleuré à la mise en
place des préconisations
ont été accomplis dans ce domaine du
foncier oralement quelques années donc
je disais que la paternité en revient en
partie
à une approfiliation collective au
niveau local
excusez-moi de vous entends plus
j'en profite pour saluer l'arrivée de
monsieur le Président du Conseil
départemental de Mayotte monsieur
Benissa housseni bienvenue parmi nous
avec son avec son
équipe
[Applaudissements]
nous avons perdu monsieur goût entre
temps
monsieur gouv vous nous entendez
[Musique]
depuis 2019 et comparateurs
vous nous entendez
en attendant
[Musique]
il y a plusieurs micros qui sont ouverts
donc c'est un peu compliqué
[Musique]
si vous si vous voulez bien
si vous voulez bien les activer votre
micro
et je vais les je vais laisser la parole
au Président je vais laisser la
monsieur le Président c'est à vous
le président
que qui est un petit empêchement de
dernière minute je parle à main ici avec
général adjoint un chef de développement
économique
[Musique]
en présentant les excuses du président
qui ont dû l'actualité
bonjour bonjour
des actions du département
dans le domaine du foncier agricole on a
souhaité chiffré pour vous puissiez
saisir le contexte
ce sera dans certains aspects plus
techniques voilà je rappelle que la
superficie agricole
utile et estimé à Marion pendant 20
mille hectares
les instruments c'est un instrument
statistique qui a été relié évalué
consacré à la production locale qui
permet de déployer
nos objectifs et qui est composé
essentiellement des terres arabes
c'est à dire culture maraîchère et
moi culture fourragère les cas de
fourragères et autres une surface
toujours en herbe périme permanente avec
les gazons sous les cocotiers et une
culture pérenne Yang vanille arbre
fruitier et café cocotier
des grandes filières qu'on souhaite
développer dans un proche souvenir la
finalement aussi la surface aux affaires
voilà en revanche
agricole
l'édifice d'apprécier effectivement
l'évolution exacte de la super ficie de
mahoraise étant donné que l'Observatoire
du parcellaire à l'école mahorel n'est
pas suffisamment alimentaire en données
je vais essayer d'aller très vite
s'agissant de la répartition de la
propriété foncière agricole le foncier
agricole maori est détenu et l'ancien
élément important par trois
propriétaires principaux le Conseil
départemental qui détient à peu près 60
% parcelles les particuliers qui
possèdent 30 % et l'état qui détient 10%
restants donc c'est
tripartit si j'ose dire le partage du
foncier agricole le problème de
l'indivision succès sera de toujours pas
résolue et là c'est un problème
structurel ça empêche tout déploiement
d'action toute politique en matière
agricole en fait la problématique de
l'indivision vous savez que la plupart
des propriétés des parcelles agricoles à
Mayotte sont à l'indivision c'est un
travail qui a été initié à sécuriser un
droit puissent avoir leur titre de
propriété mais cela n'a pas été fait
mais ce travail-là est en train d'être
poursuivi
alors je poursuis alors en ce qui
concerne les spécificités agricoles les
plus discretation les modes de
productions
et à majorité valoriser dans un modèle
intensif de ça veut dire que
on a
Monique
molécule commerciale c'est-à-dire des
manières
on a des
vous attendez
vous entend parfaitement
le fait donc
la culture
l'agriculture traditionnelle à Mayotte
vocation commerciale et une
autoconsommation donc l'agriculture
familiale reste dominante et ce sont
souvent des petites exploitations qu'il
faut moins d'un hectares c'est à dire
que on a une coexistante entre les
agriculture traditionnelle et une
agriculture commerciale et l'agriculture
commerciale la plupart de se pratique
sur des
de ce qu'on appelle le monoculture
intensif c'est des maniocs ou des ou des
bananes voilà la superficie réellement
cultivée et de 7000 hectares répartis de
la manière suivante on a des fruits qui
une production fruitière sur 3700
hectares on a une production légumière
autour de 1500 hectares et on a comme je
disais tout à l'heure le reste la
plupart de temps c'est la production de
féculents notamment les ce qu'on appelle
les bananes vertes et banales légumes en
40 à mais aussi les
manioc alors quand
actions menées pour protéger et
valoriser le fossé agricole à Mayotte
elle sort nombreuses d'abord certains
actions sont menées surtout en
partenariat avec les différents
institutions de développement agricole à
donc avant d'aller plus loin il convient
de rappeler qu'une grande partie des
personnes à l'école de parentale sont
occupés d'une manière irrégulière par
les agriculteurs ou d'autres personnes
pour des activités non agricoles en fait
le département a beaucoup de parcelles
agricoles mais la plupart de ces
parcelles agricoles sont occupés par des
personnes d'une manière irrégulière
parce qu'il y a pas eu un contrat il y a
pas eu un bail qui a été ficelé mais
traditionnellement les Maori en fait
par cela donc l'un des grandes
difficultés pour nous c'est qu'on a
comme nous allons
pour pouvoir mettre à disposition des
agriculteurs c'est par celle-là donc on
est en train de répertorier tous les
agriculteurs qui cultivent sur des
parcelles agricoles du département
l'idée se identifier ceux qui souhaitent
ce professionnaliser on les accompagne
vers la professionnalisation et ceux qui
sont plus âgés ou qui n'ont pas de la
motivation pour ce professionnaliser on
va proposer c'est par celle-là à des à
des jeunes agriculteurs ou à des
professionnels après le département
possède aussi des parcelles de très
grande surfaces comme par exemple Wendy
donc l'idée c'est que sur des grandes
parcelles agricoles que détiennent le
département l'idée c'est de morceler ces
parcelles ces parcelles là le viabilisé
par la suite en facilitant l'accès à
l'eau en facilitant l'accès à
l'exploitation agricole par la
réhabilitation des pistes agricoles et
réaliser un contrat de bail avec ces
écritures là pour qu'ils puissent pour
qu'il puisse
produire voilà et effectivement nous
afin pour terminer il existe un certain
handicap en fait
à Mayotte on a
certes des atouts parce que on a des
jeunes beaucoup de jeunes agriculteurs
qui souhaitent s'installer mais on a
aussi certains
indicats donc sur le territoire de
Mayotte l'objectif d'atteindre
l'autosuffisance à l'image et c'était
l'objectif atteignable c'est à dire que
même aujourd'hui
on est presque autosuffisant à tout ce
qui est féculents
à un nœud en production de on n'est pas
très loin un fruit à fruits et légumes
donc je vais dire que sur certains
filières sur certains filiales on est on
peut atteindre on peut atteindre
l'objectif fait cet objectif de
consuffance alimentaire par contre sur
certains filières on pourra pas
autosuffisant parce que vous avez que
les parcelles je me rappelle les à
Mayotte les parcelles
donc on a un problème d'exécuter de des
parcelles c'est qui fait que on pourra
pas on boit pas atteindre ses objectifs
là sur cette filière mais on a aussi
d'autres d'autres
difficultés des des des
freins donc une grande partie de la
production les agriculteurs sont là ils
vont peut-être
les grandes parties de la production et
détruite par les miens et les Russes on
a aussi un grand problème de vol de
production de production agricole c'est
à dire que
en ce moment en ce moment
les vols sont-elles qu'on est en train
de réfléchir comment nous prendre pour
protéger
les
productions agricoles et puis les
élevages agricoles et Petula sort aussi
victimes d'un vol au quotidien et
en train on est en train de réfléchir
avec la chambre de culture c'est
pourquoi n'est pas maître
n'est pas identifier les animaux avec
des puces électroniques pour qu'on
puisse tracer les animaux en cas de vol
mais c'est cette opération va coûter
énormément cher donc on ne souhaiterait
pas que ça soit étendu à l'ensemble des
animaux mais l'idée c'est que dans
chaque élevage
identifier quelques animaux
avec des puces pour qu'on puisse les
suivre en tout cas de pouvoir voilà
rapidement ce qu'on pourrait dire par
rapport aux fossiers agricoles
si j'ai pas été clair
à poser des questions
remercie pour vos propos de très
éclairants
et nous y reviendrons avec Dany
je vais demander à Monsieur goussi il
est toujours en ligne je suis navrée
nous avons été interrompus
sinon je passe la parole à Monsieur Yves
Michel dollar si vous nous entendez de
l'établissement public foncier
d'aménagement de Mayotte
nous sommes en ligne
monsieur goût vous vous êtes en ligne
nous ne vous voyons pas
nous sommes en ligne
voilà donc
nous avons été interrompus nous vous
voyons donc si vous avez juste quelques
mots à ajouter et puis nous passerons la
parole
à l'établissement public foncier
d'aménagement de Mayotte
je ne sais pas ce que vous avez pu
entendre de vos propos
nous avons entendu jusqu'à la coupure
nous avons tout entendu
en résumé en quelques en quelques mots
notre notre démarche c'était de dire
qu'effectivement je le rappelle foncier
est un sujet important qu'on a bien
identifié comme un défi à relever que de
nombreuses actions avaient été
entreprises avaient été identifiées et
entreprises pour apporter des premières
solutions à cette problématique qui a
été aussi évoquée par penser
départemental qui va être évoqué je le
pense par tous les participants à cette
table ronde pour dire que notre prise
d'attaque sur le foncée et l'opportunité
de disposer d'un fonciers disponible et
non pas d'un foncier
occupé pour pouvoir déployer une
stratégie à la fois l'installation mais
aussi en vue de la souveraineté
alimentaire du territoire qui est pour
nous la colonne
en matière de développement de
l'agriculture sur le territoire
et que à ce titre là l'expérité de
Mayotte
a pour mission
déjà donc de d'aménager un foncier
agricole de l'état de telle sorte qu'on
puisse avoir un démonstrateur qui nous
permettent à la fois
de pouvoir aménager équiper rendre
l'accès à ses parcelles travailler sur
les grandes agricoles et aussi
travailler avec l'établissement public à
la façon dont on peut disposer d'un son
cycle qui est intégralement
aujourd'hui par des actifs en
particulier ou des doubles actifs et
donc tout le travail établissement
public il reviendra probablement c'est
de savoir comment on va pouvoir
conjuguer une occupation longue par des
occupants sur ce foncier et la stratégie
de l'État pour pouvoir à la fois
immobiliser et s'engager dans une
démarche de souveraineté alimentaire
c'est aujourd'hui notre la pierre
angulaire de notre problématique sur un
foncier qui existe aujourd'hui l'État le
Conseil départemental se fait état de
ses propriétés foncières le Conseil
départemental et le premier propriétaire
nous disposons d'environ d'un peu plus
de 700 hectares fonciers agricoles et
donc l'idée est effectivement de pouvoir
jouer sur son conseil agricole dans la
probabilité sécurisée du moins sur le
papier pour pouvoir déployer cette
pratique voilà je vais pas aller plus
avant et après on pourra vous apporter
des éléments
plus à la fois la stratégie que nous
voulons déployer la manière dont on va
la déployer mais je pense que les
établissement public le foncier
a apporté à se
ient je vous remercie vous avez fait une
très belle transition donc je vais
laisser la parole à l'établissement
public foncier d'aménagement de Mayotte
monsieur
Yves Michel Denard
oui bonjour Est-ce que vous entendez
bien
oui nous vous entendons parfaitement
mise en place maintenant en juin 2017
donc réellement commencé à travailler à
exercer son cas de l'exercice on doit le
préemption crédit mise en place en
octobre
2000 quand vous disiez qu'il y a pas de
safer donc un Mayotte certes mais
simplement pour rappeler que le code
rural entre un article l181
189-41 indique bien que les missions des
affaires sont exercées par
l'établissement donc nous sommes nous
sommes investis dans cette de ces
missions et aujourd'hui sont les
déclinés seulement pour indiquer que
dans des missions dans le domaine des
fonciers qui concerne la question des
acquisitions foncières de régulation des
prix du foncier de tester de limiter le
mitage et le morcellement du foncier
agricole en matière d'aménagement
agricole ne sera travaillé aujourd'hui
donc sur avec une commune de vendredi
sur aménagement de leur pôle agricole
sur aménagement de la parcelle am40 qui
est une passerelle de 56 hectares ou
c'est
de la ville de Mandre à une 456 hectares
mais qui font partie donc d'un tènement
d'environ 350 hectares objectif étant de
travailler comme disait monsieur ou à
l'instant de travailler donc de façon un
petit peu expérimentale pour voir
comment on peut décliner les méthodes à
l'échelle du territoire la prise en
compte de hydraulique agricole la
qualifie d'aménagement des opérations en
matière d'agriculture urbaine hier notre
activité donc d'aménageurs du territoire
avec l'identification notamment le
circuit court de mise en place de faire
urbaine se faire des sites au niveau de
ce territoire enfin nous avons un
travail aussi donc d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs installations notamment
ceux qui ont l'installation le foncier
maîtrisée par l'établissement et aussi
un accompagnement aujourd'hui parce que
la bascité un peu vacante à un moment
donné et qu'on a sollicité comme je suis
intervenir en matière d'accompagnement
développement dans des nourriture
biologiques au sein d'un du territoire
nous travaillons nous participons en
termes d'organisation nous avons donc
une structure aujourd'hui un pôle dédié
au sein d'un établissement qui est
regroupe cet été et qui en rappelant que
le
code rural prévoit les décisions de
l'établissement en matière agricole sont
prises après avis d'une commission
départementale
qui est chargé de bien quelle est
l'action agricole non véritablement et
qui dans la composition est basée sur
les conseils d'administration des
affaires l'objectif étant de pouvoir
faire associer donc un certain nombre
notamment les professionnels de
l'agriculture aux décisions qui sont
très sur le territoire notamment en
matière de préemption
dans différents modes d'action donc
là-dessus donc nous avons la fonction
classique de sa fleur car ici
des femmes qui me paraît donc d'agir en
matière donc de préemption agricole ou
pas c'est un nombre d'acquisition
annuelle aussi sont aujourd'hui
proposées est-ce qu'on a envie de dire
ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a un an que
certaines femmes de régulation au niveau
du territoire parce que d'abord pour
certains grands forcés éventuellement
nous proposer le foncier avant de
discuter avec des acteurs potentiels
donc je prends je prends un exemple bien
simple aujourd'hui c'est les dernières
propositions de dragon ça partent autour
de 250 hectares
au niveau de l'établissement et depuis
2019 ça peut que simplement dire ce que
nous avons reçu de 714 déclarations de
l'intention d'alignées qui portent sur
233 hectares de fonciers avec un prix
moyen du foncier donc depuis l'origine
qui est à 24,78 euros le mètre carré
c'est un chiffre qui évolue donc c'est
un chiffre moyen que je vous ai donné en
sachant que nous le moyenne donc des DIY
2022 était plutôt de l'ordre de 30 euros
donc on est le prix du mètre carré
on peut considérer ce qu'on va aussi
dire ce que beaucoup de ces transactions
portent sur des petites parcelles nous
avons 85% des parcelles qui font moins
de 5000 m² et on sait quand même
agricole donc c'est cette surface qui
permet à l'agriculteurs qui fait du
maraîchage de vivre nous avons 65% des
parcelles qui font moins de 1000 m² avec
une surface médiane qui est de 550
mètres carrés ça veut donc dire que
globalement on peut extrapoler en disant
que la majorité des petites parcelles
qui sont mises sur le marché n'ont pas
une vocation agricole
aujourd'hui dansera que la CFA nous a
demandé donc pas intervenir la pression
quasi systématique en préemption suivi
par scène donc ce qui n'est pas sans
conséquence au niveau de l'ambiance
sociale du territoire si on arrive à
parfois avec des prix on sait que le
prix initial peut-être 40 euros mais on
nous annonce de la vie à 5 euros pour
espérer qu'on va partir mais on a
surtout donc des personnes qui n'ont pas
des bouffées d'agriculteurs parce que il
s'agit d'agriculteurs déclaré inscrit
nous prêtons pas dans ce cadre-là on
voit apparaître la forme de montage avec
la constitution de société à vocation
agricole écran mais qui viennent juste
des constitué pour pouvoir espérer
passer en dehors des forces cordines
donc d'appréhension nous sommes
relativement du silence mais voilà ça va
vous dire que vous avez un foncier donc
qui est relativement
onéreux que nous nous portons acquéreur
donc aujourd'hui pour être éducatif les
femmes et propriétaire de moins 75
hectares de français agricole sur
lesquels nous avons commencé donc à
installer en 18 agriculteurs qui
aujourd'hui ont installé sur le foncier
porté par l'établissement simplement
pour indiquer que la démarche préalable
avant l'installation s'agriculteur
relativement complexe c'est compliqué je
me disais non plus le Conseil
départemental tout à l'heure il y a
d'une population présente sur ce foncier
l'objectif c'est d'abord de rencontrer
les personnes qui sont prudents
présentes d'identifier leur vocation ou
pas des brigades des agriculteurs
professionnels entrée d'un circuit
normal et classique si c'est le cas on
sait les accompagner si c'est pas le cas
on indemnie généralement les cultures
qui sont sur site et on peut récupérer
le foncier pour installer donc de nos
propriétaires sans parler des aventures
conflits à voir notre personne qui se
croit propriétaire qui ne sont pas
réellement avec parfois des situations
peuvent être un peu plus complexes que
des personnes qui ont dispose d'un titre
et qui a pas été enregistré ou autre
chose c'est nature ça devient plus
complexe alors qu'on avait supporté à
cœur de la parcelle bon voilà simplement
ce que je voulais dire c'est une partie
foncier donc on achète un foncier à
environ donc les prix que j'ai indiqué
en moyenne de 10 12 euros le mètre carré
qui fait l'hectare à 90
1120000 euros avec un prix de location
donc du foncier aujourd'hui qui est donc
de l'an 2200 euros l'hectare par an ça
veut dire que récupérer nos vies il faut
le louer pendant une centaine d'années
pour espérer qu'en penser l'objectif
pour nous c'est de permettre aux
agriculteurs donc de pouvoir s'installer
dans votre condition ils accompagnent en
plus alors installation que chez les
accompagne ensemble d'opérations et
d'action
une part au niveau des laboration de
leurs différents bilans prévisionnels au
niveau donc la recherche de financement
qui soit auprès du fait Ader qui soit
auprès des banques pour assurer le
financement et nous accompagnons au
niveau des membres on nous a avons fait
ensemble de réunion ici sur le
territoire avec les organismes bancaires
pour espérer de trop essayer de
comprendre pourquoi il accompagnait pas
les agriculteurs ces choses faites nous
avons deux agriculteurs qui viennent
d'être accompagnés par une banque de la
place et qui aujourd'hui pour certains
vont pouvoir réellement développer
l'exploitation et pour d'autres nous
racheter pour un autre nous racheter le
foncier qui l'occupe donc déjà depuis
2019 puisque le premier acquisition date
de 2019 il s'agit d'une exploitation qui
produisait qui alimentait quasiment et
culturel alimenter quasiment les
principales GSM dans le territoire une
étoilation de cinq hectares le président
n'arrivait pas à vendre et en fait de
démembrer son exploitation alors qu'elle
est disposé de serre des réseaux donc
hydraulique autre chose c'est nature
que l'on aura 10 pour la préserver et la
maintenir dans l'espace agricole Morel
voici ce que je peux dire ce stade sauf
si vous voulez que je poursuivre sur les
autres questions qui avaient été qui ont
servi de base de préparation mais
simplement pour rappeler pour vous
donner les éléments de contexte de
l'intervention établissement en matière
donc de maîtrise et de mise à
disposition de fonctions agricole aux
agriculteurs du territoire
je vous remercie pour ces propos très
éclairants je vais passer la parole à la
Chambre de l'agriculture de la pêche et
de l'aquaculture de Mayotte représentée
par son directeur Monsieur Stéphane
Allard
monsieur Allard vous nous entendez
nous allons je vous propose de passer la
parole à la Fédération mahoraise des
associations environnementales monsieur
naïlan atoutman à Tibou et puis nous
reviendrons
après à la Chambre d'Agriculture
oui bonjour bonjour à tous et merci pour
pour cette invitation donc pour nous en
fait au niveau de la Fédération
nord-ouest des associations
environnementales donc on parle du
foncier agricole donc déjà bien
comprendre aussi ce qu'on appelle
l'agriculture ici parce que les
définitions ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes entre ce qu'on appelle agriculture
et cultivateur ou en tout cas la réalité
locale parce que on a des gens qui sont
siretés mais
la plupart en fait démarrer il continue
à cultiver
des champs qu'on appelle les mandats
et
quasiment tout le monde en fait il a
systématiquement son champ
[Musique]
ce qui peut poser aussi un certain
nombre de problèmes aussi parce que ces
gens-là ne se transmettent de génération
en génération et pas forcément de
manière officielle mais
la pratique est coutumière fait que on
sait que on a telle famille tel terrain
il appartient à telle famille
l'autre problématique que cela soulève
aussi ce que on va se retrouver dans des
situations où on va trouver un certain
nombre
de
champs de fonciers agricoles cultivé
dans des espaces naturels sensibles dans
des espaces
protégés et qui parfois bénéficie des
subventions publiques sur des milieux
naturels qui sont qui sont protégés et
qui peut poser un certain nombre de
problèmes donc là tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu le Dieu mais c'est de parler de
2000 hectares donc beaucoup de zones
agricole Mahoré qui sont dans des zones
qu'ils ont qu'on appelle agroforestière
parfois se trouve dans des zones qui
sont extrêmement sensibles et qui ne
devrait pas être compatible avec les
milieux naturels protégés je pense
notamment là on est en plein crise
de l'eau ici on va trouver des champs
jusqu'au
périmètre de protection
directe en fait des zones de captage par
exemple donc ce qui pose un certain
nombre de problèmes probablement de
position diffuse mais aussi en matière
de protection tout simplement de ces
zones là et de garantie en matière de
sécurité alimentaire en matière d'eau
potable d'eau destiné
à l'alimentation humaine et donc aussi
souvent aussi c'est parcelles qui sont
en indivision ou appartenant à des
familles où on sait même plus où les
trouver et qui vont générer un certain
nombre de
squattage par des personnes en fait qui
sont pas là chez eux et qui savent
qu'ils sont pas là chez eux et donc qui
exploitent des des parcelles
comme une nouvelle comme une de
sous-entendre avec toute la
problématique en fait de
d'encadrement en matière de préservation
en matière de
de pratique
agricoles donc on trouvait vraiment en
fait dans cette démarche parce que
souvent on se rend compte aussi que la
réglementation qui appliquée ici à
Mayotte n'est pas
compatible n'est pas cohérent par
rapport à la superficie du territoire
parce qu'on va appliquer des normes
métropoliaires
qui s'applique sur des espaces beaucoup
plus importantes mais ici qui vont
proposer un certain nombre de problèmes
je pense notamment au code forestier qui
va qui définit des parcelles à déboiser
qui nécessite en fait des autorisations
qui sont limitées à 4 hectares mais
quatre hectares sur 3000 territoires de
375 km². c'est énorme et ça pose tout un
tas de
problèmes en matière de préservation de
l'environnement mais aussi même pour
l'agriculture
elle-même parce que les pratiques ne
sont pas suffisamment
suffisamment encadré et ce qui va
générer des zones où une exploitation ou
une surexploitation de certaines
parcelles qui va poser des problèmes
ensuite parce que tout simplement
dépasser ne sont pas ne sont pas
rentables donc on voit être dans cette
logique
euh de mutation on commence à cultiver
ici on après ça devient pas rentable on
va passer sur une autre zone et avec la
densification de la population on a
absolument besoin
d'un cadre sur foncier agricole et
surtout d'arriver à le contenu parce que
même quand on dit c'est pas non foncé
qui appartient à l'État ou à des
particuliers
il y a pas forcément une maîtrise au
sens en fait de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
[Musique]
de maîtriser réellement quand on parle
du foncier agricole et du foncier
protégé
qu'on puisse
avoir en fait une répercussion ou en
tout cas une réalité qui correspond à ce
que à ce qu'est la réalité sur le sur le
terrain parce que souvent on a cette
cette grande différence entre ce qui est
officier et ce qui se passe réellement
sur le terrain et on le paye au
quotidien au jour le jour en matière de
biodiversité en matière de la ressource
en eau en matière de
des espèces et des espaces
je vous remercie je vais maintenant
passer la parole à la Chambre de
l'agriculture de la pêche il doit de
l'aquaculture si nous entendent
monsieur Stéphane Allard
vous n'êtes toujours pas là donc je vais
passer la parole aux jeunes agriculteurs
de Mayotte monsieur soumaya moeva
président
merci beaucoup pour ce temps de parole
alors donc pour nous la question du
français agricole et à l'image
comme on le qualifierait de l'ensemble
de le chèque de la police agricole
locale donc dans un premier temps il
convient de rappeler à la délégation que
43% des agriculteurs mahorés ont plus de
60 ans aujourd'hui
quand seulement 10% au moins de 40 ans
donc le vieillissement de la population
agricole est une problématique nationale
mais à Mayotte
il est accentué par le maintien d'une
agriculture non professionnelle qui
freine l'installation et le
développement des filières donc au
niveau notamment de
des aides surfaciques de la PAC
S ne sont soumis à aucune restriction
d'âge jusqu'à type dativité ni même de
maîtrise foncière donc couplet à ça un
manque d'incitation financières à la
transmission
donc nos aînés se retrouvent contraints
de conserver pour leur corps le foncier
agricole à défaut de partir à la
retraite
et donc ce qui fait que les agriculteurs
ont du mal à trouver du foncier pour
s'installer les jeunes en tout cas donc
par la suite on peut constater qu'il y a
des installations de d'autres personnes
qui sont parfois en situation régulière
ou pas qui vont pratiquer les cultures
avec des méthodes
peut conventionnelles souvent et à terme
c'est l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires qui sont qui sont
interdits en France et qui se retrouvent
quand même dans dans nos assiettes si je
peux dire ça comme ça donc dans ce même
temps sur 15 études diplômés de la
première promotion
brevet professionnel du responsable
agricole donc le BPA à Mayotte seulement
si si jeunes ont peuvent justifier d'un
d'un foncier et donc prétendent à une
installation avec les investissements
européennes
donc pour les 9 autres donc c'est
c'est comment dire
c'est un parcours de commentaire pour
trouver du foncier donc les 9 autres
mais aussi 94% des porteurs de projets
qui sont passés au pays à savoir que au
niveau des porteurs de projets passés au
pai
on a à peu près à
on a à peu près 200 porteurs de projets
qui cherchent du foncier et qui n'en ont
pas
donc en
2001 en 2022
c'est à peu près
94% de ces gens-là qui n'ont pas de
foncier agricole qui sont à la recherche
donc ce sont entre 3 et 5 années longs
d'un chemin assez long pour avoir une
maîtrise foncière donc là entre 3 et 50
c'est vraiment il y en a qui qui
s'arrête en route il y en a qui
continuent mais il y a quand même ce
gros problème de français donc cette
situation elle maintient les
agriculteurs compétents et diplômés dans
une situation de semis
professionnalisation puisque devant soit
exploiter des terres sans bail ou titre
foncier
ou et donc sans possibilité
d'investissement soit trouver un emploi
alimentaire
repoussant donc au second plan
l'activité agricole
donc c'est c'est là la dynamique qui se
crée aujourd'hui
à Mayotte faute d'une politique forte
sur le foncier agricole
donc nous afin d'améliorer l'accès à la
maîtrise foncière le syndicat
porte les propositions suivantes donc
concernant comme on l'a dit au début il
y a donc les trois bailleurs le CD
l'État et
l'État et les privés donc du coup
concernant le CD
en ce qui concerne les
fonciers en zone agricole donc faisons
l'objet de revendications au nom de
l'occupation coutumière le syndicat
demande qu'un critère de portage de
projet agricoles soient rendu
obligatoire à savoir et passage par le
pays une formation en agriculture ainsi
que la rédaction d'un projet agricole
donc sans une telle mesure
les terrasses on voit ce privatiser se
diviser et à terme à s'ajouter à la
dynamique d'urbanisation sauvage
concernant les terrains du CD
en ce moment donc le faisant pas l'objet
de revendication au nom de l'occupation
au quotidien une interdiction pure et
simple de la session ou location de
terrain des personnes non agricoles
là concernant les terrains privés en
zone A ou en zone N
il serait bien donc l'application de
mettre en place l'application plus
récente de l'article
l181-31 du code rural et de la pêche
maritime
en deuxième point la mise en place
effective des recommandations 3 et 4 du
précédent rapport slatorial à savoir la
rédaction d'une commission
donc la réactivation pardon d'une
commission consultative de borruraux et
la création de groupes fonciers
agricoles
élément essentiel au développement du
formage en Mayotte donc
un seul 1% des exploitants aujourd'hui
loueur terrain donc on est très très
loin et en troisième troisième point
enfin donc ça serait le portage d'une
politique de valorisation des terres
inculte
ou en friche par les femmes avec un
support
du département pour le modèle de la de
la Réunion
concernant les terrains du CD ou de les
femmes mises en location
la facilitation de l'installation à
titre de logement principal sur la
parcelle louée donc là il s'agit de
faciliter les agriculteurs à plus
s'installer sur leur exploitation qui
diminuerait d'un côté les vols et tout
ce qui suit
et donc aussi la mise en place de
village agricoles que les femmes a parlé
tout à l'heure de
parcelles
[Musique]
viabilisées pour pour les agriculteurs
parce que là-dedans en fait c'est
des parcelles souvent qui sont louées
aux agriculteurs des parcelles qui n'ont
qui n'ont pas d'infrastructure donc pas
d'eau pas d'électricité pas de route
donc l'idée de village agricole que le
syndicat apporte depuis plusieurs années
déjà c'est vraiment viabilisé des des
parcelles à forte potentiel agricole
sous forme de de villages agricoles
enfin dans l'optique d'encourager la
transmission est réduire la rétention
des terres agricoles à nos données il
est nécessaire de reformer les
conditions d'attribution de la PAC tout
en le rassurant un revenu en ouvrant une
discussion sur un minimum retraite
couplé à des aides à la transmission
notamment au niveau du département
ouvrir l'ensemble de ces terres privées
au fait marge permettrait d'augmenter
rapidement et de façon importante les
installations de nouveau agriculteurs
sans initiative forte sur une meilleure
maîtrise du Foncia agricole
l'agriculture mahoraise est vouée à
l'échec
le syndicat est convaincu que les
agriculteurs professionnels notamment
les jeunes présents sur leur
exploitation
usant des techniques raisonnées voire
biologiques et entraînant les cours
d'eau d'entretenant les cours d'eau et
leur terrain sont aujourd'hui à Mayotte
les plus à même à assurer une
préservation et développement de
l'agriculture il faut donc nous
encourager à faciliter nos installations
sur des terres d'exploitation accessible
et sécurisé
moi je m'arrêterai là pour mon
intervention et on répondra bien
évidemment aux questions tout à l'heure
merci je vous remercie infiniment pour
toutes ces précisions et comme à
l'ensemble de tous les intervenants nous
sommes nous sommes partisans de
récupérer de vos contributions écrites
qui éclaireront nos travaux donc je vais
laisser la parole à
la Mutualité sociale agricole puisque
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles de
Monsieur Allard ah vous êtes là ah
pardon excusez-moi je vous prie
je vous ferai d'accepter plus de
d'excuses donc je vais laisser la parole
à Monsieur alors
merci je suis désolé
depuis trois jours en Tanzanie c'est une
horreur là pour le wifi et ça a marché
pendant une heure et après ça marche
plus bon bref
au niveau de la chambre avec couture on
est je vais aller très vite parce que
j'ai entendu l'ensemble des débats le
constat il fait il y a des difficultés
par rapport au fonciers à l'accès aux
fonciers pour déjà un recteur mais aussi
pour directeurs qui voudraient
s'installer sur Mayotte et
la difficulté elle est liée un peu à
l'histoire
il fait que par exemple nous sommes
missionnés par le Conseil départemental
pour développer le fermage et le serrage
ne fonctionne pas du tout parce que ce
n'est pas
un propriétaire si donne son bien
enfermage j'ai l'impression donc ça
c'est quand même un souci et ça bloque
énormément le déploiement de
l'agriculture sur maillot on restait et
je pense que tout le monde a dit on est
1,4 hectares en moyenne donc ce qui est
pas grand chose en termes superficie de
production et donc on reste dans ma
culture vivrière et pendant la culture
de conseils
[Musique]
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
et tu penses qu'une des solutions ça
serait que et le Conseil départemental
est l'État met en place justement le
carnage pour les jeunes agriculteurs qui
vont bien sûr être si réutilisés bien
sûr à des rares et messages bien sûr
dans les règles et
ce potentiel de foncier qui existe qui
n'est pas utilisé après il y a aussi les
problèmes de de sur ces terres parce
qu'il y a des
occupations inégales parce qu'il y a mon
avis donc je reviens pas là dessus
et troisième chose que je voulais dire
pourquoi on est en Tanzanie avec mon
Président et parce que il y a des terres
agricoles en Tanzanie qui sont prêts à
louer justement et pour
un objectif qui est de nouvelles
appropriation de Mayotte mais ce serait
pourquoi pas aller vers une
[Musique]
un développement régional de
l'approvisionnement avec des haricots
mahorés qui pour investir de les
agriculteurs peut-être enseigné j'en
sais rien on n'a pas encore creusé le
sujet complètement mais pour résoudre un
problème de d'approvisionnement la
population en produits agricole frais de
qualité
locaux parce que je ne sais pas si vous
avez vu aussi des chiffres mais on a
Mayotte est fourni à 60% par la France
15% par le Brésil 5% par Argentine
celui-là l'Afrique du Sud
il y a des solutions locales qui doivent
exister peut-être Madagascar peut-être
la Réunion on doit s'améliorer la suite
et pour cela pour dire que le 36 est
vraiment vraiment un souci au niveau de
Mayotte et je suis désolé de pas vous
voir
vous remercie maintenant nous allons
terminer ce tour de table avec la
mutualité sociale agricole madame Karine
nouvelle
oui bonjour à tous vous m'entendez bien
parfaitement très bien merci donc juste
pour resituer un peu la problématique
effectivement la MSA d'Armorique donc
qui couvre les populations agricoles du
Finistère et des Côtes-d'Armor est en
charge de la gestion de la protection
sociale des agriculteurs Mahorais depuis
le 1er janvier 2015
depuis cette date donc les agriculteurs
Mahorais ont obtenu un statut qui leur
permet de bénéficier de la protection
sociale donc sur le volet maladie en ce
qui concerne les indemnités journalières
maladie en cas d'arrêt de travail et
également la prise en charge des frais
médicaux et également sur le volet
retraite donc avec la retraite de base
ensuite en 2019 donc il y a eu la mise
en place de l'assurance accident du
travail et de maladies professionnelles
et également en 2019 la mise en place de
la retraite complémentaire obligatoire
donc aujourd'hui au 1er janvier 2023 ça
d'Armorique Mayotte couvre
1338 chefs d'exploitation Mahorais
52% ont plus de 60 ans
elle couvre également 350 conjoints
collaborateurs 50 aides familiaux au
total donc on a 2471 personnes qui ont
un droit ouvert en maladie
alors concernant les problématiques de
protection sociale quelques quelques
points de repères concernant la
filiation puisque avant 2015 le statut
d'agriculteur n'existait pas à Mayotte
puisque les agriculteurs et leurs
familles relevaient de la caisse de
sécurité sociale de Mayotte sans que des
cotisations ne leur soit appelées ce qui
fait que les agriculteurs professionnels
n'ont ouvert aucun droit à la retraite
avant 2015
à partir de 2015 pour être affilié à la
MSA l'agriculteur doit exploiter une
surface minimum de deux hectares P alors
ce qu'il faut relever également c'est
que cette notion d'obligation
d'affiliation n'est pas bien intégré à
aujourd'hui par la population agricole
d'autant plus que l'attribution des
aides Pâques de politique agricole
commune cette attribution elle n'est pas
soumise à l'obligation d'être affiliée à
la MSA contrairement à ce qui est prévu
en métropole donc cela a un fort impact
également sur les agriculteurs qui ne
sont pas affiliés
autre point d'attention concernant les
cotisations donc les cotisations elles
ne sont pas calculées sur les revenus
professionnels mais en fonction de la
surface pondérée nous avons la loi du 13
décembre 2000 qui prévoit un certain
nombre d'exonérations de cotisations
pour les territoires
d'outre-mer et les exonérations sont en
espèces appliquées sur les cotisations
maladie prestations familiales et
retraite de base donc concernant
particulièrement les agriculteurs
mahorés nous avons donc des cotisation
sur les indemnités journalières à MEXA
donc qui est applicable depuis 2015 et
qui est forfaitaire à hauteur de 180
euros une cotisation indemnité
journalière à Texas donc applicable
depuis 19 2019 pardon et calculer en
fonction de la surface pondérée et une
cotisation retraite complémentaire
obligatoire appliquée également depuis
2019 et aussi basé sur la surface
pondérée
alors ce qu'il faut relever c'est que
malgré les exonérations le taux de
recouvrement des cotisations reste
faible à Mayotte autour de 20%. il a
cependant évolué depuis 2015 grâce à la
mise en place du prélèvement bancaire en
2019 et également grâce à des opérations
de communication qui ont été menées
localement
alors je vais passer la main Ayo à nos
frais directeur adjoint pour revenir sur
des points plus spécifiques de l'impact
du foncier sur la protection sociale
bonjour à tous vous m'entendez bien
aussi
parfaitement
juste aussi pour revenir sur sur
une nouvelle 52% de chef d'exploitation
ont plus de 60 ans et dans les nouvelles
affiliations ce qu'on constate
fréquemment ce sont des agriculteurs qui
s'installent justement à l'âge de la
retraite
donc c'est souvent des des
fonctionnaires ou d'anciens salariés qui
donc qui ont qui avait déjà un terrain
et qui finalement à arriver à l'âge de
la retraite finissent par aller en tant
que agriculteur parce que de fait ils
sont dans les critères d'affiliation et
ce qui fait que du coup on a donc on a
52% de nos chefs de fondations qui ont
plus de 60 ans et seulement 7% des chefs
d'exploitation qui ont moins de qui ont
moins de 40 ans alors autrement sur sur
les impacts par rapport à la
structuration et la gestion du foncier à
Mayotte donc il y en a plusieurs alors
nous encore une fois on n'a pas on n'a
pas de compétences spécifiques en la
matière
mais ce qu'on vous relate c'est les
éléments qui nous sont relatés par nos
par les agriculteurs que nous pouvons
donc on a on a pu constater à plusieurs
reprises des exploitants agricoles qui
se voyaient réduire leur parcelles alors
soit parce qu'ils exploitaient sur un
domaine forestier ou sur des parcelles
qui étaient devenus inaccessibles à
cause de l'état des routes ou encore à
cause de l'érosion aussi donc c'est ce
sont des critères qui ont nous ont
souvent été remontés et donc au delà de
cette perte d'exploitation donc ça
génère donc une diminution des
déclarations de production et donc comme
l'expliquait Carine nouvelle les
cotisations sont assises sur les
productions en tout cas les surfaces
pondérées déclarées et que cette cette
baisse de cotisation appelée entraînera
du coup à long terme notamment une
baisse de la retraite qui pourront
percevoir une fois qu'ils en ont l'âge
la diminution de la parcelle peut
également générer une désaffiliation
parce que si comme la aussi expliqué
même si la surface exploitée en expert
pondérées descend en dessous du seuil
d'affiliation de la MSA donc pour ces
personnes notamment dans ce fait dans
l'agriculture et la seule activité ça
aurait fait pour 2 € trouver sans
protection sociale et donc si les droits
aux prestations maladie restent actives
pour les frais de santé ils ne sont plus
couverts notamment pour le risque
maximum du travail une maladie
professionnelle ou encore un des
militaire et bien sûr il ne cotiseront
plus pour leur retraite alors sur la
difficulté d'accès à la parcelle
donc nous avons organisé il y a une
dernière mission à Mayotte une table
ronde autour de la prévention du
mal-être
et donc au delà des difficultés en lien
avec
la sécurité les vols qui ont été qui ont
déjà été évoqués là les principales
principales difficultés liées aux
foncier qui a été exprimée mais
concernait l'accès aux exploitations
donc de nombreuses exploitants nous
relâchent cette problématique qui
entraîne également pour eux une perte
d'exploitation là encore en lien avec
les difficultés d'entretenir et
d'aménager la parcelle ou encore d'y
accéder via un véhicule pour transporter
leur production cette perte
d'exploitation entraîne là encore une
incapacité à payer les cotisations cela
pourrait essayer avec le plus pouvoir du
métier de la couverture des invités
journalières on a la direction du
travail comme on les veut que tout à
l'heure et à plus long terme donc de ne
pas pouvoir bénéficier encore une fois
de la retraite
donc sur la politique agricole commune
donc comme ça a été déjà évoqué et
contrairement à la métropole les
conditions d'affiliation à la NSA ne
figure pas les critères d'égalité à
l'attaque pour les agriculteurs de
Mayotte et donc ce point de
réglementation entraîne déjà une
conservation du frontières agricole par
des personnes dont la profession n'est
pas agriculteur ni à titre principal ni
à titre aussi secondaire et qui
bénéficie du coup de la Pâque au-delà de
ça ça génère une distorsion de
concurrence entre les exploitants et ça
qui ont des charges sociales à payer
vis-à-vis des exploitants qui eux sont
non-officiels et qui n'ont pas de charge
sociale et qui bénéficient de la pacte
malgré tout
alors il y avait des questions aussi que
vous nous posiez par rapport à l'état de
la protection sociale et en quoi ça
pourrait constituer un frein à
l'installation on maintient des
agriculteurs dans leur métier sur ce
sujet donc on a un nom important de
dispositif de protection sociale qui à
ce jour ne sont ne sont pas mis en
oeuvre pour différentes raisons et
contrairement à la métropole et qui
renforce ainsi le sentiment d'inager
d'inégalité vis-à-vis de la métropole
pour nous assurer et aussi de rejet de
la MSA et qui accentue les difficultés
d'accès aux soins et d'accès aux droits
alors il y a un certain nombre de
listations encore une fois qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas appliquées notamment
en lien avec le congé maternité le congé
paternité donc la législation prévoit
que les exploitants agricoles peuvent
bénéficier d'un congé maternité pas
terminé mais par le biais d'un service
de remplacement et en l'absence de
possibilités de reprend un service parce
qu'il n'y a pas de service de
remplacement à Mayotte ils ne peuvent
ils ne peuvent plus pas procéder à une
embauche directe
contenue du contexte social sur l'île et
donc il ne peut pas bénéficier des
indemnités journalières pour cela et
donc
il conviendrait donc de faire évoluer
ses textes pour prendre en compte la
situation de Mayotte et laisser la
possibilité aux exploitants et
exploitantes de bénéficier des
directement des IJ des industriels
maternité paternité
par rapport à la retraite à la SPA et
également à la parcelle de subsistance
pour les agriculteurs
la retraite agricole de base donc
n'ayant pas n'ayant été mise en que
depuis 2015 à Mayotte les exploitants
agricoles n'ont plus acquérir de points
et de validation de l'année d'activité
que depuis cette année-là pour la
retraite complémentaire obligatoire
c'est même 2019 et à ce jour il n'y a
aucun texte qui prévoit une validation
gratuite de points pour les années
antérieures à 2015 si ce sujet
dépasse le cas du champ de
responsabilité de la MSA les
représentants des différentes
organisations agricoles nous remontent
régulièrement cette demande et donc la
MSA donc on vous relie cela et donc au
delà donc ça génère de l'incompréhension
de leur part et ainsi les agriculteurs
soit ne pas s'affilier étant donné qu'il
bénéficions pas une retraite convenable
soit ne pas prendre le retraite et donc
à ne pas libérer du foncier
au 1er janvier 23 il faut noter que donc
on a quatre retraités agricoles à
Mayotte seulement et le montant de leur
retraite aussi entre
74,81 par mois et 292 euros 40 par mois
les donc les retraites les plus
importantes sont liées au fait que ces
assurés eux ont bénéficient de la
retraite complémentaire obligatoire
s'agissant de la SPA donc c'est la
location spéciale pour les personnes
âgées qui n'est pas la location
spécifique pour les personnes âgées de
métropole donc c'est un dispositif qui
est géré par la Caisse de Sécurité
Sociale de Mayotte et donc qui permet à
l'exploitant de bénéficier à compter de
65 ans sous conditions de ressources
tout en serrant son activité donc de
dans mon montant de la SPA qui
correspond à moitié du montant de la
métropole ce qui n'est pas non plus
incitatif à prendre à prendre sa
retraite et ce qui est donc pas
incitatif à libérer à libérer les terres
agricoles il y a 246 agriculteurs qui
bénéficient la SPA à Mayotte et par
contre il est important de signaler que
l'ASPA est récupérable sur la succession
le calcul de la retraite agricole est
basé sur les années d'activité et donc
un agriculteur comme on vous l'a dit ne
peut pas cotiser depuis 2015 et donc
l'absence de validation de trimestre et
de points gratuits pour les paires de
ses dents on constitue le principal
frein au départ à la retraite et par
conséquent à la session du chantier
alors il y a un autre sujet et donc en
lien notamment alors la date c'est
également présente quicon qui concerne
l'inadaptation de certains coefficients
de pondération qui sont appliqués aux
productions déclarées parce que comme on
vous l'a dit il y a il y a la surface
qui est exploité appliquée un conflit
coefficient de pondération et ce qui
donc conduit à déterminer le montant de
la cotisation et donc certains
coefficients de pondération nous sommes
pas adaptés au contexte local et induit
des cotisations appelées qui sont
souvent trop importantes face aux peu de
revenus générés par l'activité
d'exploitant et les cotisations n'étant
pas payées des droites telles que les
indemnités journalières ou la retraite
complémentaire obligatoire ou encore
l'accident du travail ne peuvent être
appliqués pour une grande
personnalisation parce que un exploitant
qui n'est pas à jour de ses cotisations
ne peut pas bénéficier de ces de ces
prestations
il apparaît également que certaines
cultures ne sont pas bien identifiées
avec notamment les futurs maraîchirates
qui sont pourtant très répandues sur
Mayotte et qui le bénéficient pas de
connexion de pondération
et je terminerai par les éléments
relatifs donc là plutôt à l'accès aux
droits et donc à la complémentaire santé
solidaire donc qui n'est pas mise en
oeuvre aujourd'hui à aller prévue pour
le 1er janvier 2024 donc aujourd'hui il
y a un dispositif d'exonération du
ticket modérateur qui est en place 2019
pour pour donc qui permet finalement à
l'assurer bénéficier d'un 100% santé
pour bénéficier de ça ça lui impose
malgré tout chaque année dans reformuler
le monde et de nous adresser son avis
d'impôt pour s'assurer les seuils de de
qui lui permet de bénéficier de cette
exonération forcément
la à la fois la barrière de la langue la
culture locale la culture administrative
fait que la plupart de nos agriculteurs
peinent à nous transmettre cette mise à
jour là et lui parvenons pas
contrairement à la caisse de sécurité
sociale à bénéficié des flux directs de
la Direction générale des finances
publiques pour pouvoir faire bénéficier
aux agriculteurs de 100% santé ce qui
peut constituer là aussi un frein à
l'installation et au maintien dans la
dans la fonction d'agriculteur
donc les différentes problématiques que
nous avons exposées peuvent paraître un
peu technique
mais leur résolution a été essentielle
pour le bon télépoiement à la fois la
protection sociale des exploitants
agricoles et de leur famille ainsi que
des que de la professionnalisation du
monde agricole et donc nous restons ni
pour répondre à toutes vos questions je
vous remercie je vais commencer par
laisser la parole à Tani
et puis après avec Lopez
merci Madame madame la Présidente
je salue l'ensemble
de nos invités qui nous ont énormément
enrichi aujourd'hui avec leur éclairages
mes collègues sont édifiés parce qu'ils
entendent
et notamment par la dernière
intervention et
merci d'avoir insisté Madame Monsieur de
la MSA pour participer à cette table
ronde c'était c'était nécessaire
ce moment est important parce que c'est
au travers de vos auditions que
l'ensemble de la délégation aux
outre-mer
aura
une idée précise de ce qui se passe dans
ce département dans ce jeune département
et cette étude
a été proposée par victoire jasmin je
j'en profite pour la remercier c'est la
triste de Guadeloupe
qui dans le prolongement des études que
nous avons effectuées de 2015 à 2017 sur
le foncier en général à notre mère a
proposé à la délégation qu'il a accepté
à l'unanimité une étude complémentaire
sur le foncier agricole
à l'aune des crises que nous venons de
traverser et qui mettent en évidence en
exergue le fait que
il faut réduire les importations et
produire davantage
localement pour atteindre vers
l'autosuffisance à alimentaire et
je tenais à le préciser parce que il n'y
a pas de parti pris
c'est une étude transpartisante tout le
groupe politique du Sénat sont ici et il
n'y a pas d'a priori et j'aimerais
vraiment tranquilliser mon ami chez
livre Donard vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure le texte qui a mis en place les
femmes et qui a prévu que l'appréhension
à Mayotte doit être exercée par les
femmes je le connais d'autant plus ce
texte que c'est nous ici à la Délégation
aux outre-mer qui avons proposé la
création des femmes des EPS de Guyane et
de Mayotte et au bout de deux ans
d'existence l'établissement public fon
d'aménagement de Guyane a émis la
volonté de mettre en place une safer
parce que c'était nécessaire en plus de
de l'epfa
et la question se pose pour Mayotte
aussi et lorsqu'on entend
notamment l'association de protection de
l'environnement je pense que
à raison légitimement peut se poser
cette question parce que parmi les
missions de sa faire il y a aussi la
protection de des espaces des espaces
naturels or nous savons que notre île
est minuscule par rapport aux autres
territoires 374
km², fortement peuplé très dense très
densément peuplé et dans cette île il
faut à la fois
construire pour habiter et circuler il
faut aussi produire
pour l'agriculture et faire et faire un
certain nombre
un certain nombre de choses
pardon pour ces
mots
en préambule parce que je voulais
vraiment situer ce moment hyper hyper
important à l'issue de notre rapport que
j'ai le bonheur de conduire avec
mon ami ma collègue
et l'air vivait vivait le Pez
et bien nous émettrons un certain nombre
de préconisations et c'est
enrichi de vos éclairages que nous nous
permettrons de mettre ses préconisations
mais pour tout simplement améliorer
améliorer la situation
je n'aurais pas
énormément de questions à poser comme la
rappeler la présidente tout à l'heure
vraiment nous vous demandons un effort
complémentaire de mettre par écrit les
réponses que vous avez en partie donnée
le Conseil départemental a donné
toutes ces réponses si nous pouvions les
avoir par écrit pour nous permettre de
de mieux mener notre notre étude notre
apport ça serait une excellente chose
une question
transversale parce que à écouter les uns
les autres en fait
tout va bien tout va bien parce que au
niveau du conseil départemental il y a
une excellente programmation qui est qui
est prévu et effectivement si nous
allons dans cette programmation pour
attribuer des parcelles aux agriculteurs
ça serait une très bonne chose
au niveau des services de l'État au
niveau de les femmes aussi sauf que nous
avons un problème c'est que les
agriculteurs et notamment les jeunes
agriculteurs n'arrivent pas à avoir
accès à ces à ces terres agricoles et ma
question c'est comment faire
qu'est-ce qui se fait qu'est-ce qui
serait bien d'être fait un terme de
coordination
en termes de
en fait d'échanges entre vous
tout et tous acteurs de la terre de la
terre agricole mahoraise pour améliorer
les choses
quel délai encore une fois depuis la
crise covid de la guerre à l'Ukraine
l'obligation de produire local se fait
encore plus encore plus ressentir et
donc comment coordonner tout ça pour que
ce qui se fait bien
auprès des services de l'État auprès de
la cape auprès du département auprès de
les femmes auprès
de de ses partenaires puissent
bénéficier aux agriculteurs qui
souhaitent produire local merci
je vais laisser la parole maintenant à
notre ami vivait Lopez
oui merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et à tous
effectivement je suis ravie de conduire
cette mission avec Tani bien évidemment
en colère et je voudrais quand même tout
de suite dire qu'un agriculture il n'y a
pas vraiment de politique les poireaux
les carottes ou autres légumes ne sont
ni de droite ni de gauche et nous avons
vraiment tous bien besoin de nous
agriculteurs pour vivre donc merci à eux
de essayer de nous apporter tout cela
merci mesdames et messieurs pour toutes
les explications que vous nous avez
apportées alors bien évidemment j'ai
bien compris le fonctionnement agricole
est une priorité évidemment pour nous
tous et je crois que c'est Monsieur
nailan à thouma natibou qui a évoqué le
fait qui a fait un peu la différence
entre le foncier protégé et le foncier
agricole qu'en est-il réellement du
foncier protégé
est-ce qu'il est vraiment nécessaire de
le protéger est-ce qu'une partie de ce
foncier protégé ne pourrait pas servir
aux fonciers agricoles ça c'est une
première chose ensuite vous avez évoqué
et ça j'ai pas très bien compris est-ce
que les agriculteurs ont le droit de
construire sur le propriétaire agricole
leur hangar et éventuellement leur
habitation pour surveiller les vols mais
qu'en est-il le jour où l'agriculteur ne
veut plus pour X raisons va un sol sans
hangar et sa maison à quelqu'un d'autre
qui n'est pas du tout agriculteur est-ce
que c'est autorisé comment ça se passe
là j'aimerais bien avoir des petites
explications
vous avez parlé également du service de
remplacement pour le congé parental mais
est-ce que le service de remplacement ne
pourrait pas servir entre pour autre
chose c'est à dire peut-être pour des
congés quand les gens ou pour la maladie
quand les gens sont malades ou veulent
partir en congé le service de
remplacement n'est pas spécifique au
congé parental
et une autre petite question quelles
sont les menaces concrètes que fait déjà
peser le changement climatique à Mayotte
et puis j'ai une autre petite question
vous l'avez eu dans le questionnaire qui
vous a été donné je suppose au regard de
l'objectif de taux suffisance
alimentaire et des caractéristiques du
foncier agricole Mahoré quelles sont
réellement les handicaps et les atouts
de Mayotte surtout pour l'installation
de jeunes est-ce que les normes
européennes aussi sont un frein à
l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
voilà pour l'instant c'est le seul
question que le petit point que
j'aimerais éclaircir je vous remercie
beaucoup
Monsieur donneur a souhaité prendre la
parole donc je vais lui
la vie transmettre
oui merci Monsieur
globalement si vous avez eu l'impression
que tout va bien sur évolue foncier non
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
simplement ça vous fera un peu un état
des lieux
[Musique]
une action en révision de fluide de
façon quasi systématique dès que le prix
du foncier dépasse des 40 ou 50 euros
voir en dessous
même sur les petites parcelles nous
plaindre façon systématique pour éviter
justement des effets pervers donc c'est
la réalité du terrain en capsule
établissement n'est pas administré par
simplement il me semble que c'est en
Guyane c'était issu c'est la suite au
mouvement des 500 frères il y a une
décision qui étaient prises à mettre en
place cette affaire au niveau de la
Guyane simplement je ne suis pas d'après
les objets je suis pas certaine qu'elle
soit déjà complètement l'activité
d'autant plus que la notation finance de
station beta de 200000 euros donc
forcément permis de travailler mais les
frais de continuer à travailler beaucoup
de domaines donc c'est à l'école état
migracieusement à sa disposition
polarisation donc le chemin
d'exploitation des équipements
d'aménagement peuvent aussi donc ici sur
Mayotte donc une attraction notre
activité c'est fait avec zéro centime de
notation d'établissement de l'État
ministère de l'Agriculture qui a notre
PSD nous avons aussi une négocié il y a
des affaires de principes le préfet d'un
Mayotte et le service de Mayotte on se
sent beaucoup investis qu'on puisse
bénéficier d'une dotation
aujourd'hui c'est pas la volonté
lentement de conseil administration de
l'établissement qu'on a pu réussir à
obtenir à fonctionner je rappellerai que
une affaire c'est d'abord un société
différemment une société anonyme qui
donc qui n'est pas censé vivre
uniquement des subventions et subsistes
donc des collectivités ni de l'État et
qu'aujourd'hui donc nous avons notamment
sur l'exercice passé à qui quasiment 3
millions d'euros donc de foncier une
recette en matière location qui est
l'ordre de 10000 euros donc voilà
simplement parce que l'offensif occupé
les difficultés de l'élibération du
foncier sont réels ils ont été amené à
la recruter des agents qui sont les
agents du terrain qui vont voir et faire
des enquêtes de terrain qui vont aussi
identifier les agriculteurs les
conditions qui sont pas toujours très
simple mais ils arrivent on arrive avec
force de persuasion parfois des Dr
relativement longs nous le foncier
appartenait à la politique c'était plus
de 18 mois de discussion pourra
récupérer le foncier et installer donc
déjà des agriculteurs
à Mayotte ont été avec l'action au
contraire l'action de conduite par
l'établissement alors c'est simplement
ce que je vais indiquer non oui il y a
des réelles difficultés sur le terrain
sont significatives la question de l'eau
c'est à nous alors je sais que nous
allons faire des tests avec avec la DAF
et à Mayotte ça peut en voir ce qu'on
peut se faire sur l'opération ce secteur
donc de trélie
à l'histoire que vous connaissez sur ce
territoire pour voir comment on peut
réussir à ces agriculteurs il y a une
urgence ici au niveau c'est parti
installation d'agriculteur vous avez
notamment le président de la VM qui
cherche du foncier qui a 24 hectares
l'État sur ces 350 hectares de fonciers
en 4ni n'est pas en mesure de pouvoir
installer parce que pour s'exploité sur
les 56 hectares de la N40 chacun nous
travaillons nous en fait une enquête de
terrain et sinon 132 agriculteurs qui
sont installés là-dessus
donc une minimum et une dizaine de
siriés l'anticotise aujourd'hui c'est
comment récupérer son fier pour
installer ces agriculteurs comment
collectivement on arrive à trouver
mettre en place des modes de fer pour
pouvoir avoir un visage
au faveur du développement agricole du
territoire je ressemble bien notre droit
coutumier j'entends bien tous ces
éléments là donc aujourd'hui c'est bien
la question qui se pose sur le fond
c'est de savoir quelqu’un qu'est-ce
qu'on veut pour ce territoire à faire de
développement notamment agricole et
comment on arrive à mobiliser son site
qui appartient les départementales d'une
part puisque je rappelle que 92 % de
franchi départements et en zone
naturelle soit en zone agricole comme on
arrive à le mobiliser pour installer
dans les conditions satisfaisantes des
agriculteurs qui entre la planète
d'avoir
des revenus suffisants peuvent mettre
contribuer au développement et à la
tolonie alimentaire du territoire oui je
vous dis à 10 ce sont réelles c'était
simplement pour appeler un peu les
éléments de contexte pour parler des
prévisions avec les acteurs on va parler
de l'attribut du français à des
agriculteurs
aussi l'établissement nous mettons en
place faisant des appels à projets nous
avons en syndrome des personnes autour
de la table qui participent à ces
séances donc à drtm que ce soit le
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs que ce
soit l'ADAF que ce soit donc la fmae qui
est un pays aussi et que ce soit la
CAPAC qui sont donc des partenaires avec
nous cette volonté quelque part dans de
développer le territoire mais rien n'est
rose tout est difficile mais on a la foi
allez vous y arrivent
je vous remercie
quelqu'un souhaiterait-il intervenir
pour répondre aux questions posées par
les deux rapporteurs
je veux bien
ah oui je veux bien rajouter en fait
quelques moules par rapport à par
rapport à la question qui a été posée
sur le réchauffement climatique en fait
effectivement ça a un effet direct sur
le rendement sur la production agricole
d'une manière générale vous savez que en
ce moment à Mayotte la saison des pluies
et de plus en plus courtes ce qui
impacte réellement la production
Vivienne donc les le rendement pour la
production de banane voire même de
manioc et Annette et Annette c'est un
effet direct de la de la sécheresse donc
par rapport à ça
par rapport à ça en tout cas pour les
autres cultures nous avec la Direction
de l'Agriculture en tout cas de la date
on essaie de rendre certains
exploitations agricoles autonomes le
terme est beaucoup plus
optimiste mais l'idée c'est de récupérer
pour chaque bâtiment d'élevage que nous
aidant on essaie de mettre en place un
système de récupération des eaux de plus
qui permet par la suite d'alimenter les
le l'élevage donc ça c'est ça c'est
quelque chose de de très important pour
nous et par rapport au réchauffement
climatique vous savez que le département
a un centre de recherche agronomique
donc dans le centre de recherche
agronomique nous sommes en train de
travailler sur des variétés locales
délaissées presque par les agriculteurs
cette variété là par exemple des tomates
cerises ou de ou de l'origine qui sont
beaucoup plus résistants à maladies et
qui ne souffront pas par rapport à la
déficithique qui ne sont pas très
consommateurs d'eau donc l'idée c'est de
revenir sur ces espèces là là qui
résistent à la sécheresse qui résiste à
la chaleur pour toujours avoir cette
capacité à produire après je suis très
rajouté un petit mot par rapport à
l'autosuffisance alimentaire nous
travaillons en ce moment sur comment
augmenter la production des des élevages
comment rentabiliser les exploitations
de manière générale la production
animale donc on a un travail puisque on
l'a dit à Mayotte on a des parcelles
très exigus des répétiteurs parcelles
nous travaillons avec ma détesta l'idée
c'est d'importer des fourrages
liberté depuis Madagascar pour pouvoir
nourrir leur nourrir nos animaux à
Mayotte et ce et ce projet d'importation
de fois déshydraté de Madagascar et
compléter par un autre projet
d'importation de vaches de race pure
depuis
la métropole pour continuer à améliorer
notre notre pour l'amélioration
génétique d'une manière générale voilà
ce que je souhaiterais apporter en
complément par rapport à deux questions
qui viennent d'être posées
merci y a-t-il d'autres signes y a-t-il
de préférence
oui oui
[Musique]
excusez-moi madame nouvelle mais il y a
un retour je ne sais pas s'il faudrait
peut-être couper des micros
alors
[Musique]
en fait c'est à votre niveau qui a
il y a pas deux appareils ouverts de
votre côté non
vous avez quelqu'un d'autre de connecter
dans la pièce avec vous
ah ça va mieux ça va mieux c'est mieux
d'accord
excusez-nous ça ne fonctionne pas il y a
un écho
OK
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est mieux ah oui c'est
parfait très bien alors simplement pour
revenir sur comment favoriser
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
alors c'est pour vous vous remonter les
échanges que nous avons pu avoir avec
les acteurs locaux et du point de vue
des aspects de protection sociale tout
d'abord nous il nous apparaît important
de favoriser le départ en retraite des
agriculteurs comme vous avez pu comme on
a pu vous l'indiquer on a 52% des
agriculteurs qui ont plus de 60 ans donc
il est important de pouvoir libérer des
terres libérer du foncier pour que les
jeunes agriculteurs puissent s'installer
et cela passe certainement par la
nécessité d'améliorer le niveau des
retraites des agriculteurs puisque comme
on vous l'indiquez le dispositif des
retraites est très jeune donc il date de
2015 pour la retraite de base et 2019
pour la retraite complémentaire
obligatoire ce qui fait que les droits
sont extrêmement limités et de ce fait
en l'absence d'octroi de points gratuits
pour valoriser ses retraites on voit
qu'on a un certain nombre d'agriculteurs
qui ne prennent pas leur retraite et
donc qui garde le foncier le deuxième
point c'est l'importance aussi de
renforcer tout ce qui concerne les
obligations d'affiliation donc comme
vous l'indiquez on voit que c'est une
notions qui n'est pas bien assimilée à
date et pourtant qui est essentiel pour
permettre d'ouvrir les droits aux
accidents du travail l'igy maladies les
droits retraites et donc il est
important que l'on puisse je dirais
renforcer une communication sur ce sujet
et également prévoir
comme cela se passe en métropole de
prévoir que l'octroi des aides Pâques
n'intervient que s'il y a une
affiliation à la MSA cela permettra
effectivement dans ce cas d'un attribuer
la Pâques que aux agriculteurs qui sont
professionnels donc de ne plus attribuer
de pas que au non professionnel et très
certainement donc du coup d'avoir un
meilleur fléchage de ces fonds publics
européens vers des agriculteurs
professionnels voire du coup une
revalorisation du niveau de la PAC pour
ses seules agriculteurs
je vous remercie alors Monsieur Philippe
goût soit intervenir
madame Lopez non effectivement je vais
pas
directeur de l'espace mais tout va bien
cependant aujourd'hui on a mis en place
des dispositif
grâce à la collaboration de tous qui
permettent d'aller vers quelque chose de
plus ciblé de manière définie et de plus
cohérent en termes d'action publique
c'était ça que nous attendions aussi on
va parler de on a parlé de la Commission
de France essentiel qui permet de mettre
des titres de propriété de sécuriser la
propriété on a parlé d'outils comme la
cdpas qui a un rôle de protection des
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
donc on n'avait pas cette écosystème et
ce qui est important c'est quand même
que dans une situation
les
partout et par nous aussi service de
l'État bien entendu comme très difficile
on a quand même quelques murs d'espoir
parce qu'on a su collectivement mettre
en place et le législateur il y a
fortement contribué
des outils sur lesquels on va pouvoir
s'appuyer pour développer des politiques
publiques de masse il n'existait pas on
pouvait pas les mettre en place
aujourd'hui on a quand même des maths
qui permettent de l'événement en place à
l'avenir ceci dit c'est parce que
justement la fluidité du marché naturel
de la transmission n'est pas garantie
pour les raisons qui ont été
parfaitement
par les hommes et par les autres que
nous au niveau des services de l'État
nous avons souhaité mobiliser notre
ancienne agricole et on en arrive au
point de mur c'est à dire le dire
c'était une chose nous avons commencé à
le réaliser en validant avec les
services de la Direction des finances
publiques une délégation de gestion de
ce foncier agricole de l'Etat vers
l'établissement public d'aménagement
notamment sur la parcelle 40 de 56
hectares on parlait donc voyez nous
avançons pour les enquêtes au niveau
local vivent à déterminer qui en termes
d'occupation à vocation est restée au
fil de l'agriculture professionnelle qui
a vocation à être relocalisé délocalisé
pour pouvoir libérer des terres à
l'installation et c'est là qu'on entre
dans le mur et donc il va falloir être
imaginatif
à s'en rendre dans une logique de confit
d'usage entre des années entre des
qui
occupe ces terrains dans le cadre
d'occupation couturière ancestrale
traditionnelle lointaine et donc on va
rentrer dans un constitutions
de l'État or votre souci n'est pas
d'alimenter le conflit notre société
vient de trouver collectivement et y
compris avec nos collègues jeunes
agriculteurs qui peuvent être
fascuritateur dans la démarche de
trouver la manière de résoudre ces
conflits d'usage pour faire en sorte que
puisse sur Internet et intégration
intégralement
occupée trouver des opportunités pour
libérer les parcelles suffisamment
importantes pour installer des jeux mais
on peut estimer que quelqu'un qui a deux
hectares sur ce
foncier
à en posséder moins ou du moins en
occuper moins
propriétaire dès lors qu'on aura la
capacité de l'aménager le dialyser et
donc par la même sécuriser
la mesure où le nombre est aussi à des
situations on en est là aujourd'hui avec
l'établissement public
[Musique]
cette ambition de nous portons en
mettant de foncière
que on enlève peut-être on aura besoin
aussi de l'éclairage de tous les
conflits de législateur comment on peut
avancer sur ce domaine pour répondre aux
questions madame Lopez
protégé
malheureusement alors par contre là on
observe une atteinte à cet espace
protégés par une agriculture clandestine
que tout le monde connaît à Mayotte et
qui justement met un mâle les espaces
particuliers parce qu'une partie de
l'agriculture
clandestine et par des gens qui l'ont
mis droit
se fait par le défi fin de ses parties
et au niveau des services de l'État au
niveau de la gare nous avons un service
forestier et qui travaille en
collaboration avec les services du
département ceux de l'OMS et accompagné
par les forces de l'ordre pour justement
lutter essayer de lutter contre ce
déclenchement et nous intervenons sur
des parcelles qui ont été défricher qui
sont en face de l'être pour justement
détruire les productions agricoles
irrégulières
justement essayer de juguler cette
propension à dénaturer les espaces qui
doivent et je rappelle puisque vous
parliez madame également de la menace du
changement climatique et quelles sont
ses répercussions on sait très bien que
la forêt c'est un réservoir important
d'eau c'est une manière de capter l'eau
à Mayotte aussi comme ailleurs bien
entendu et que cette déforestation
effectivement est particulièrement
nuisible à l'eau et que le Conseil
d'usage entre l'eau de l'esprit et le
agricole sera nécessairement tranché au
profit de l'eau domestique pour rebondir
sur ce qui était dit par nos collègues
les associations environnementales nous
arrivons au jour dans une situation
dramatique catastrophique à Mayotte avec
une saison des pluies qui a été
particulièrement peu abondante nous
sommes à la fin de la saison des pluies
nous approchons de la fin de la saison
des pluies et les réservoirs sont
ce qu'il avait ce qu'il est dit jusqu'à
présent les réservoirs servaient à faire
le tampon entre
on rentre aujourd'hui dans des
logistiques qui vont être
particulièrement difficiles et des temps
qui vont être particulièrement
difficiles à passer le logement logement
sur l'essentiel agricole
la CDPA la commission de parentale la
protection de l'espace atomique voire
régulièrement devant elle dans cette
commission des projets déposés pour
pouvoir
construire l'exploitation améliorer les
les outils d'exploitation y compris le
logement sur le foncier agricole et nous
donnons des autorisations dès lors que
la Commission est en mesure de s'assurer
de la légitime prétention des demandeurs
à avoir une véritable activité agricole
et avoir s'installer c'est une façon de
sécuriser et là les jeunes agriculteurs
ont raison entre autres c'est une façon
aussi de sécuriser les productions quand
on sait que la prédation des machines la
prédation du vin sur les productions
agricoles les particulièrement sensibles
de voir une collègue agriculteur voire
le travail détruit en quelques instants
par des gens qui viennent
pillés ces productions quelque chose
d'insupportable normalement et
financièrement bien entendu donc
aujourd'hui on en est plutôt à essayer
de favoriser ces constructions dès lors
qu'on n'est pas capacité de
leur légitime prétention la question
ensuite de ce qu'elle deviendront si
agriculteur à reste son activité
je vous avoue que on en est pas là
encore c'est pour l'instant pas le sujet
le sujet et date de permettre
l'installation voilà donc rapidement
quelques éléments que vous voulez
apporter un sujet qui est porté aussi
par tout le monde arrêter là cette
question des aides européennes
qui ne sont pas conditionnés à une
affiliation effectivement jusqu'à
présent ce n'était pas conditionné
j'aurais quand même rappelé que 80% de
la production agricole à Mayotte c'est
du vivrier que les espaces fait qu'elles
ont été attribués jusqu'à présent je dis
pas que ne pas être va réviser la
philosophie qui du président elles ont
une logique d'accompagnement social de
tout petits producteurs de quelques
centaines voire milliers de mètres
carrés tout petits producteurs qui sont
des producteurs qui produisent pour en
vivre c'est une façon d'accompagner ce
vibriller qui participe de l'autonomie
alimentaire du territoire bien sûr nous
sommes focalisés nous aussi des
prioritairement sur une agriculture
émotionnel parce que le volume de
production est le gisement de production
est là et ne serait-ce que pour
alimenter demain les marchés puis pour
alimenter la restauration collective la
restauration scolaire je rappelle que ce
sont 100 000 repas qui pourrait être
servi à nos jeunes scolaires à Mayotte
et aujourd'hui
c'est comme si je vous conseille donc
effectivement oui
avec cette mobilisation de nos
sensibilité et il faut pas négliger
cette agriculture vivrière qui est un
fort amortisseur social qui est un moyen
de subsistance unique pour des centaines
voire des milliers de tout petits
producteurs qui de toute façon n'auront
pas vocation compte tenu des surfaces
qui peuvent mobiliser à s'engager dans
une agriculture professionnelle
aujourd'hui encore ce livre
ça souveraineté alimentaire du
territoire
donc on peut réfléchir à cette
dispositifs mais je rappellerai quand
même que ces dispositifs aujourd'hui on
sert ses aides à des personnes qui sont
non affiliées c'est à peu près 700
personnes sur 6000
agriculteurs entre guillemets donc ça
peut être un élément et on peut y
réfléchir tous ensemble et bien entendu
nous serons autour de la table pour
réfléchir à cette infléchissement qui
devait y avoir un réfléchissement mais
ça sera loin de résoudre les difficultés
que nous connaissons
je vous remercie avant de passer la
parole à Monsieur Aufray je souhaiterais
saluer notre collègue Mohamed Hassani
qui nous a rejoint en visio donc cher
Mohamed si vous si tu abdela pardon
pardon pardon je suis vraiment vraiment
vrai si tu souhaites exprimer tu as la
parole
bon on me signale qu'il est parti entre
temps donc je vais laisser la parole à
Monsieur Auffret
notamment la question sur les services
de remplacement
des questions qui a été posée par la
scénariste Lopez
alors effectivement un service de
remplacement et notamment si on prend
l'exemple de de la métropole sert à
autre chose que que pour voir un
remplacement pour les congés maternité
ou paternité notre propos était dans le
sens où en termes de législation de la
sécurité sociale le critère pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'indemnités journalières
enfin de d'un congé pardon d'un congé
maternité ou d'un congé paternité
prévoit volontairement donc le passage
part d'abord un service de remplacement
puis une embauche directe puis puis le
pouvoir bénéficier d'unité journalière
ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas le cas
que pour les personnes qui
souhaiteraient prendre des vacances ou
autre chose là effectivement en
métropole il y a ils peuvent y recourir
directement et librement en fonction de
ça il y a même aussi servir
d'emplacement qui sert aussi en termes
de d'accompagnement social pour des
personnes en difficulté enfin voilà il y
a tout un tas de dispositif qui est qui
existe comme ça en métropole mais en
tout cas déjà la première chose pour
pour Mayotte ce serait effectivement de
permettre ce dispositif parce qu'on a pu
rencontrer notamment des personnes qui
étaient en congé maternité qui
continuaient tous les jours à aller sur
leur exploitation alors qu'elles étaient
à 8 mois grossesse qui n'avait pas
forcément vu donc vu de de médecins de
médecins pour les accompagner durant
grossesse et donc forcément un service
de remplacement aurait pu aurait pu
venir pallier à ça donc voilà c'était
pour préciser ça mais bien sûr qu'un
seul emplacements peut servir à autre
chose que de pallier au congé maternité
paternité c'est juste que pour la
maternité de maternité c'est un
dispositif qui est prévu réglement par
le code de la sécurité sociale et alors
juste pour compléter par rapport à
l'intervention aussi de nos différents
partenaires et on a évoqué la PAC mais
quand tout à l'heure on évoquait la
condition d'affiliation à la MSA comme
permettant de bénéficier de
l'accompagnement ou des différentes
aides qui sont proposées là par
différents partenaires c'est voilà c'est
ce n'est pas que pour la PAC c'est aussi
pour tout autre accompagnement que vous
pouvez vous pouvez vous pouvez leur
remettre on parlait tout à l'heure de
récupérateur d'eau depuis ou de pouvoir
bénéficier de foncier c'est vrai que la
question ne serait-ce que au-delà de
l'affiliation c'est de la connaissance
que nous avons parce que vous pouvez on
a très bien pu rencontrer aussi des
personnes qui étaient qui faisaient
accompagner mais qui avait par exemple
eux étaient bien affiliés mais qui avait
une dette sociale dans le sens où par
exemple depuis leur affiliation ne payez
pas leur cotisation sociale donc c'est
important d'avoir cette vigilance et ce
partage entre entre là tous les tous les
partenaires qui sont qui sont dans réuni
réuni ce jour pour ne serait-ce que
s'assurer que voilà les aides et
l'accompagnement sont aussi sont aussi
portés finalement auprès de soit
d'exploitation qui sont fiables ou
d'exploitation qui sont tout simplement
effectivement affiliés et qui bénéficie
des mêmes règles et en tout cas pas de
distorsion de concurrence avec des
exploitants qui eux ne seraient pas
merci je vais laisser la parole à
Monsieur motiva qui malheureusement l'a
demandé depuis tout à l'heure et
malheureusement nous n'avions pas vu
donc je lui le prix d'accepter nos
excuses
merci de me donner la parole déjà pour
vous dire que je suis d'accord avec une
grande partie de ce qui s'est dit au
niveau de des habitats de changement
climatique installation mais je voudrais
quand même revenir sur l'installation
l'installation aujourd'hui si enfin
c'est directement lié au foncier et
quand on voit que sur la programmation
de 2014 de 2014 à 2020 sur la PAC la
dernière programmation on a pu installer
que dit pas plus de 10 agriculteurs
c'est que effectivement il y a un gros
problème au niveau de la politique
agricole locale tant bien même on a mis
beaucoup de dispositifs en place donc
parmi celles ces difficultés c'est déjà
le foncier le foncier qu'on va à quel
point c'est
compliqué d'avoir une assise foncière
mais pour ceux qui l'ont derrière c'est
c'est les autres problématiques liées au
préfinancement et autres donc je vais
pas trop m'attarder là-dessus je
pourrais dire que au niveau de la PAC
c'est vrai que par rapport à la
situation du territoire
comment dire on est assez large sur les
les anciens
au niveau des anciens c'est vraiment un
besoin de renouveler les générations à
partir de là c'est leur donner
les bons comment dire les
bonnes conditions pour partir je
regrette un peu de ne pas avoir entendu
la l'intervention de la directrice ça a
coupé entre temps mais je pense que ça
va dans le sens où vraiment il faut
mettre en place des
les conditions que leur permettraient
d'aller aisément dans une retraite parce
que tant que une bonne partie de ces
agriculteurs là qui pour la plupart ont
un foncier déjà entretenu ou il y a déjà
une début d'activité pour les reclaires
ça reste assez compliqué de faire une
reprise si ces personnes-là ne part pas
dans des bonnes conditions donc du coup
nous on avait demandé on a beaucoup
travaillé avec avec Yoann offre
notamment pour justement avoir ces
conditions d'ailleurs il y avait eu un
entretien avec Monsieur sénateur que
j'ai pas pu participer en début de mars
mais nous notre objectif vraiment c'est
d'aller dans ce sens là pour vraiment
qu'on puisse faire une transmission
réussite après on comprend que on
consiste que depuis 2000 2015 ça c'est
un fait mais on demandait le rattrapage
avec une un élan de solidarité nationale
bon après il y a des choses qui sont
possibles avec la bonne volonté du monde
d'autres qui sont un peu moins mais
vraiment c'est dans cette dynamique là
qu'on aimerait
poursuivre et aussi au niveau des
formations donc les formations du BPA
donc jusqu'à
2000 2020 2021 d'ailleurs on avait le
CPA qui a été arrêté au profit du BPA
sauf qu'on a eu qu'une seule session
celle de 2021 2022 pardon et depuis lors
on a pu d'offres de formation
normalement c'est le conseil
départemental qui
qui finance ces formations un panel de
formation parmi laquelle on retrouve le
diplôme du BPA et là aujourd'hui on est
un peu inquiet parce que l'offre de
formation n'est toujours pas sortie ce
qui fait que le lycée agricole ne peut
pas encore lancer des inscriptions pour
cette formation qui est
importante enfin sans la formation BPA
on peut pas prétendre à l'installation
d'un d'un chef d'exploitation pour
bénéficier des fonds européens
voilà c'est un peu ce que ce que je
voulais dire là dessus et au niveau de
des accompagnements avec un finance
voilà donc au niveau de du BPA on
voulait insister sur le fait qu'il
faudrait que le département ou les
femmes en tout cas ceux qui ont la
maîtrise foncière puissent garantir un
foncier aux agriculteurs qui sont
diplômés ou qui sont en phase dans la
formation en tout cas parce que c'est
vrai que en métropole et à la Réunion on
demande à ce que la personne qui
la personne qui s'inscrit au BPA en
amont un foncier sauf qu'à Mayotte avec
tous les problématiques qu'on rencontre
c'est pas toujours le cas donc du coup
c'est quelque chose qui est fait en
Guyane et nous on aimerait que ça soit
appliqué à Mayotte à savoir dès qu'un
jeune et diplômé
a
qu'on puisse lui garantir un foncier
derrière et pas qui passe deux trois
quatre ans à essayer de régulariser ou
acheter ou à avoir un bail ailleurs
aujourd'hui les femmes a du foncier le
département
Océa du foncier
ça serait bien vraiment qu'on soit un
accord avec ces jeunes formés avec un
projet qui sort tout qui sortent de
l'école qui puissent être accompagnés de
façon efficace l'accompagnant
l'accompagnement y est mais aujourd'hui
l'efficacité n'y est pas trop on passe
le temps à tourner en rond à droite à
gauche et au final c'est les personnes
qui vont abandonner parce que en plus de
ça il y a les problèmes de vol sur les
petites parcelles qu'ils ont commencé à
entretenir vraiment la problématique et
les elle est là
et puis voilà bon il y aura d'autres
choses de toute façon comme on l'a dit
en faisant des contribution écrite de
tout ce qu'on aura dit
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
il permettez-moi de vous féliciter pour
votre engagement parce que je suis très
attachée à la formation des jeunes et à
titre personnel si je puis relayer
appuyer votre demande je le fais avec
beaucoup de plaisir j'aimerais passer la
parole à notre collègue Bernard Fournier
s'ils souhaitent s'exprimer non donc
Tani aurait une dernière question
puisque cette table ronde est vraiment
très très enrichissante et nous ne
voyons pas le temps passé mais
malheureusement nous sommes contraints
par le temps et en me signale aussi que
Monsieur atibou souhaite s'exprimer donc
je le laisse où je te laisse la parole
en premier c'est juste une petite
question que
lui il aura il aura la réponse c'était
pour savoir si
[Musique]
notamment Monsieur le Directeur de la
DAF parmi les améliorations à apporter à
la situation du foncier agricole de la
Mayotte vous aviez d'ores et déjà
identifié
des nécessités d'évolution législatives
parce que
nos rapports sont assez scrutés et y
compris du gouvernement et beaucoup de
nos préconisations dans le passé on
avait d'ores et déjà fait l'objet de
projet législatif d'amendement
législatif du gouvernement notamment les
femmes notamment la cuve est-ce que vous
vous avez déjà
identifié
ce genre d'évolution
de vous répondre alors pas au niveau
foncier
important
et des Giens c'est cette question de
l'accès à la retraite alors ça va
peut-être pas régler est-ce que le
législateur peut s'emparer de cette
problématique à Mayotte qui permet de
rentrer dans une logique de de
transmission installation de faire en
sorte qu'un agriculteur dès lors qu'elle
a offensé sécurisément faut-il qu'il
invente ses
qualités toujours le cas et si on arrive
au niveau peut-être je sais pas c'est
des évolutions législatives qui peuvent
être envisagées et à faire en sorte que
un système qui est aujourd'hui est
particulièrement pénalisant dans un
la contenu de la jeunesse du système en
parlant de côté 2015 les premières
si on pouvait entrer dans une logique de
ces actualités de retraite de
renforcement de cette de cette
accompagnement des agriculteurs dans
leur dans la mesure où la transmission
est un enjeu fort à Mayotte comme le
disait
sur des terrains qui sont aujourd'hui
déjà aménagés d'établir l'exploitation
on aurait peut-être là un vecteur qui
permettrait d'assurer cette transition
des générations c'est le premier point
je pense que c'est essentiel c'est ce
qu'on avait fait remonter à travers des
dispositifs
à travers ce qu'on appelle la loi MAIF
parce qu'il était pressenti comme
pouvant être la loi Mayotte à l'époque
et qui pourrait être repris aujourd'hui
par le Sénat sur cet accompagnement à la
retraite des agriculteurs mahorés parce
que aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
quand même que 80% des des habitants du
territoire vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté un minima et que donc parfois
le petit foncier dont jouissent ces
anciens et les seuls manières de
survivre donc tant qu'ils n'auront pas
un équivalent retraite leur apportant un
minimum de capacité à subvenir à leurs
besoins du quotidien en matière de
rupture particulière on arrivera pas
engager ce processus installation
transmission pour le reste sur le
dossier ce travail qu'on est en train de
mener avec l'établissement public pas
encore mais peut-être que
reviendront vers le Sénat de loin vers
le législateur un peu plus tard pour
pour envisager quelques quelques
dispositifs mais comme je vous dis pour
l'instant on essaie de faire valoir
cette intelligence col
lective contre des occupants des
prétendants une logique de souveraineté
alimentaire pour vous déployer et de
faire en sorte de voir si ce que nous
cette ambition d'important arrive à se
réaliser
je vous remercie donc je passerai la
parole avant de conclure à Monsieur ATI
merci Madame pour
cette
parole en fait je voulais intervenir sur
le sur le foncier d'abord protégé donc
ce que la question était posée est-ce
que on peut envisager une agriculture en
fait sur les sur les zones protégées
a priori ça serait non pour certaines
d'un certain nombre puisque on vient de
voir la mise en place sur le territoire
de réserve nationale naturelle national
mais après ça serait vraiment du cas par
cas parce que on est souvent sur des
zones aussi avec des fortes pentes des
zones en jeu notamment en termes de
préservation de la ressource en eau mais
on a des occupations qui sont déjà là
qui sont qui sont existants et il y a
des initiatives donc qui ont été menées
notamment avec des conventions
agroforestière qui consistait à intégrer
ces agriculteurs là sur des zones qui
s'y prêtaient avoir des conventions et
accompagner pour avoir en fait des
pratiques agricoles qui n'étaient pas
incompatibles avec les milieux mais
c'est vraiment dur du cas par cas
concernant le changement climatique
ça a été soulevé à plusieurs reprises on
vit une situation dramatique en ce
moment dans un matière d'eau et souvent
on a une
accompagnement à l'installation agricole
qui n'intègre pas du tout la
problématique de l'eau donc souvent on
va voir en fait des agriculteurs qui
vont se servir directement
dans les rivières qui se font ensuite
verbalisés par l'administration qui les
a installés d'administration qui les a
installé l'administration de manière
générale parce qu'ils vont être
installés par la DAF ou le département
mais après l'ADN va passer derrière pour
les pour les contrôler ou les organiser
parce que tout simplement ils font des
prélèvements
illégal dans les rivières donc essayer
une vraie problématique qu'il faut qu'il
faut intégrer quand on installe les
agriculteurs qu'on intègre aussi cette
problématique de l'eau parce que vu les
difficultés en matière d'alimentation en
eau potable on va avoir des conflits
d'usage dans ce sens là
sur l'autre point en matière de j'ai
entendu de sur le
les agriculteurs et le vivier il faut
surtout pas je pense notamment aux
collègues des jeunes agriculteurs
l'agriculture vivrière je pense pas que
ça soit celle qui va poser ou qui qui a
un obstacle direct avec
l'installation des jeunes des jeunes
agriculteurs puisque
quand on parle de 80 % de production et
quand on regarde par rapport en fait aux
besoins du territoire la marge elle est
encore bien grande mais seulement il
faut organiser et structurer tout ça par
rapport à l'installation notamment des
gens qui vont partir à la retraite ici à
Mayotte des maorilles ont une relation
très particulière par rapport au
fonciers à la terre de manière générale
parce que nous en fait à la naissance on
enterre le placement sur le foncier et
généralement il est très peu probable en
fait que des anciens
qui ne sont plus à mesure de pratiquer
leur activité agricole qui est qu'ils
acceptent de laisser des à quelqu'un
d'extérieur à la famille donc ça c'est
une dimension qui est vraiment à prendre
en compte comment on va faire en sorte
pour que parce que le foncier il est
destiné à être transmis à la génération
qui vient et non pas à une transmission
agricole et c'est une réalité qui va
falloir je sais pas comment trouver
la solution mais il faut en tenir compte
si on veut que ce foncier puisse être
réutilisé pour rassurer peut-être
éventuellement les propriétaires qui
peuvent éventuellement le reprendre ou
sinon encourager aussi au sein des
familles qui à mon sens serait beaucoup
plus
acceptable en tout cas pour les pour les
anciens parce qu'on voit souvent des
gens qui vont de maintenir en activité
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas tout
simplement lâcher
[Musique]
l'offensive donc voilà en quelques mots
les quelques éléments que je voulais
apporter donc cette autosuffisance
alimentaire on entend parler et
régulièrement on essaie ailleurs
d'encourager des pratiques qui ne se
font pas ici à Mayotte on a des choses à
apporter au niveau national et il
faudrait qu'on intègre notamment ses
aspects d'agroforés ces aspects en fait
démarrer qui essaie de cultiver leur
chambre mais seulement il faut
les encadrer et les intégrer
je vous remercie donc nous allons
conclure pas d'autres il n'y a pas
d'autres intervention
à Vivette oui non moi je n'ai pas une
question je voulais simplement saluer le
directeur de la charronnerie culture
monsieur Stéphane Allard que j'ai aperçu
tout à l'heure puisqu'il est de chez moi
et donc je voulais lui dire bonjour
Stéphane j'espère je suis ravie de voir
que vous allez bien et que vous vous
plaisez là où vous êtes bonjour Stéphane
je sais pas si longtemps
je pense je sais pas
bien sûr merci à tout le monde pour vous
expliquer
avant de avant de conclure j'ai noté un
point à travers toutes les interventions
c'est aussi la nécessité d'adapter la
législation aux réalités du territoire
donc la différenciation territoriale et
la cheville la colonne vertébrale des
travaux de la délégation aux outre-mer
initié par mon prédécesseur Michel Magra
et à laquelle la délégation reste très
attachée je parle sous le contrôle de
notre président Stéphane Artano à ce
titre je souhaiterais vous remercier
pour toutes vos interventions qui ont
été particulièrement et éclairante je
remercie tanie et pour son implication
sans faille au service de son île parce
que franchement
Tani est très très impliqué pour
pour Mayotte et je tiens à le remercier
infiniment aussi Abdallah à Sani qui est
un peu plus timide mais avec qui
défend aussi ardemment son territoire
et nous sommes preneurs de toutes de
toutes vos contributions et ce rapport
on est la preuve cette table ronde et la
preuve que le Sénat reste l'assemblée à
l'écoute des territoires
au revoir à tous